[Música]
ah
bueno hola gracias gracias por la
invitación
vamos a ver si en 18 minutos
charlamos y
fundamentalmente
interpretamos
de qué se trata esto
bueno yo me llamo mario parado y soy
ciudadano de acá de funes como bien dice
la palabra cocreador acá aparece un poco
lo que anunciaron recién
me voy a parar
en algunos porque bueno lógicamente que
todos
sería algo aburrido el primero hace ya
unos diez años en realmente no recuerdo
cómo fue que surgió pero bueno una idea
de convocar a diez chicos de diez años
de diez barrios de la ciudad de funes
para hablar de diez temas conocidos como
calidad de vida 10 temas relacionados a
la calidad de vida tiramos algunos
algunos indicios para ver de qué podía
hacer y ya se hablaba hace unos 8 años
de esto de bicisendas de residuos de
bueno de la inseguridad y fue un
detonante para un par de años después
convocar a 10 políticos y ver
con 10 de las personas que nos gobiernan
esos mismos temas después bueno la
alimentación saludable más basura 0 es
importante porque hay una gran relación
en lo que es la alimentación y los
residuos
el festejo de cumpleaños de la ciudad
conocido como expo calidad de vida que
tuvo cinco ediciones en este mismo lugar
fue algo que para mí que vuelvo decir
soy un ciudadano común me sirvió
muchísimo para poder aprender cosas que
no había visto en la escuela y que al
día de hoy les creo que ninguna ningún
centro educativo cede como artes
orientales energías alternativas ahora
quizás sí
pero bueno me nutrió de una experiencia
además de conocer personajes que si uno
no los convoca si no uno nos los va a
decirle benítez que estoy armando esto
uno no tiene la posibilidad de
conocerlos bueno
[Música]
está este tipo de actividades
acá ven algunos de los afiches de los
tantos que hubo hasta todos mezclados y
después fueron surgiendo otras
actividades siempre sucede que cuando
uno empieza a hacer cosas
una cosa te lleva a la otra y hubo bueno
todas esas actividades creadas digo co
creado y me paro en esta palabrita
maravillosa porque nadie puede hacer
nada solo y no se debe hacer nada solo
somos una especie como los perros son
los gregarios eso significa que
necesitamos del otro entonces co-crear
es la forma más maravillosa que tenemos
para pasar nuestra vida para hacer todo
sin entrar en filosofar vuelvo a la
huella ecológica que fue el camino donde
yo después de dar todas esas vueltas y
de conocer tanta gente tan maravillosa
dije bueno como hago para que toda toda
esta información poder canalizar la y
poder ser más eficiente y poder lograr
de que mayor cantidad de personas
tomen conciencia primero y después bueno
desarrollen todo lo maravilloso que
estábamos empezando a conocer y surge
recién decía el presentador
una de las cosas creadas es la primer
guía que la tengo acá en la mano
sobre la ciudad de funes y de cómo
interpretarla
nosotros estamos hoy en una en una
sociedad de una forma de vida que
necesariamente tenemos que volver a
aprender lo obvio
en la guía hablamos de calma y hablamos
de volver a saludarnos hablamos de cosas
que quizás resulten básicas pero que son
las que por ahí nos han torcido un poco
esa huella y hablando de huella
dice mejorar la huella ecológica bueno
huella ecológica es un conozcamos que
huella ecológica como impactamos cada
uno la huella ecológica es un término
uno cuando bublé a poner huella
ecológica y te sale 10.000 cosas es un
concepto muy ecológica es como nosotros
les impacta impactamos como individuos y
como comunidad
a una región al medio ambiente hay
formas de impactar los buena sin formas
de impactar los realmente negativas todo
el tiempo lo estamos impactando aunque
no nos demos cuenta
pensemos
pensemos acá y también una frase que en
la feria funes orgánica que fue una
feria que hicimos varias veces ahora se
descontinuó la idea de la feria funes
orgánica es feriar poder mostrar lo que
producimos frutos pensemos en lo que
funes acá son todos los lunes alguien
que no sea de funes o de roldán de la
zona muy poquitos bueno
funes y esta zona ya sabemos
interpretamos vemos cualquier patio de
cualquier casa y fácilmente nos damos
cuenta de que
producimos constantemente
pensemos también
e
que cada metro cuadrado de la ciudad de
funes y de roldán produce residuos
cortamos el césped y en que se
transforma en un residuo
y la relación orgánica cuál es claro
hay una relación que tenemos que tener
en cuenta acá lo vamos a ver mejor
y les pido que repasen cuando van
andando en bici o recorriendo la ciudad
y vemos esos montículos de ramas en
cualquier esquina en la zona periférica
y cuando vemos ramas empezamos a ver una
bolsita de cualquier cosa o decisiones o
de televisores
y
cuando nosotros desde huella ecológica
estamos tratando de no solamente de
pensar y de hacer de contagiar
entendemos que relacionará orgánicamente
las cosas en la clave porque si nosotros
podemos como dice chipeado de ramas en
cada barrio y reducir el volumen de
ramas vamos a estar logrando dos cosas
primero dejar de generar el foco para
que después vayan las bolsitas y vayan
los televisores y todo lo que se
amontona la otra parte es el compostaje
esto que ven acá hoy le acabo de
descubrir una función a esta mesa es una
compostera
levanten la mano en lo que saben que es
una compostera
bien bueno debería ser porcentaje mayor
pero bueno para eso estábamos la
compostera como dice ahí 50 por ciento
de los residuos es un objeto que desde
el club de huella ecológica estamos
tratando de impulsar para que en cada
casa haya una porque porque del 100% de
los residuos que todos todos generamos
la mitad dentro de esta caja la podemos
transformar de una manera totalmente
mágica sin hacer nada prácticamente en
algo maravilloso que es el abono de
nuestros mejores alimentos y 50% es
muchísimo
imaginen los contenedores que vemos
llenos y rebalsados por la mitad
imaginemos también el dinero que
dejaríamos de estar usando en eso para
usarlo en otra cosa
y sigamos pensando orgánicamente
porque no solamente la basura que
producimos es orgánica hay un 30% más en
lo que es papel cartón plástico vidrio y
otros que si nos organizamos
si nos organizamos podemos no solamente
tener un impacto menor sino encontrar
oportunidades muchísimas las vecinales
los clubes las escuelas hemos hecho
alguna maratón se están haciendo hay que
darle mayor protagonismo y los veo a
ustedes y veo que son protagonistas
porque están acá
para poder generar muchísimas maratones
porque van a poder no solamente resolver
montones de situaciones que se dan en la
calle sino tener recursos para hacer
viajes para lo que se les ocurra y lo
pienso porque cada uno está en una casa
en un barrio en una vecinal en un club
hay muchísima muchísima oportunidad en
esto como estamos muy bien
bien sentir y contagiar el punto
complicado como hacemos para que otros
se involucren
bueno
nosotros en el club de huella ecológica
estamos trabajando ya en funes en roldán
y en fisherton que es el barrio de
rosario que tiene la misma puesta en
escena que la nuestra
los tres clubes tenemos muy claro que
tenemos que por un lado para que mayor
personas se involucren seguir con la
propuesta de en cada casa una compostera
y tenemos una idea que acá de donde se
les pedirá ayuda es de armar una
un proyecto que todavía no está lanzado
porque nos está faltando ayuda y créanme
que yo vine a esta charla para esto para
pedir la ayuda a ustedes de una
propuesta de llamada la basura le
ganamos por goleada a cancún es en esta
región tenemos montones de tenemos
varios deportistas
de alto rendimiento goleadores algunos y
no voy a dar nombre ni clubes para no
generar ningún tipo de bueno estas
personas nosotros las queremos convocar
para que nos ayuden a hacer una campaña
de difusión a la basura realmente hay
que ganarle hay que ganarle por goleada
porque sobre todo en esta zona donde
todavía no tenemos desde el gobierno
políticas conscientes y contundentes a
estas personas les vamos a pedir que nos
ayuden a generar una campaña que permita
que mayor cantidad de personas
practiquen compostaje de que podamos
tener chapeadoras para poder bajar la
cantidad de ramas en los barrios y
generar con todo ese dinero que créanme
que es mucho
es mucho el dinero de toda esta
situación que estamos charlando
poder bueno realmente como decimos
minorizar es este impacto y encontrar
oportunidades
no solamente estamos hablando de dinero
estamos hablando de calidad ambiental de
poder respirar el aire puro de que el
agua esté sana
y
bueno ven en el afiche al lado desde el
compostaje porque compostar lo estamos
hablando esta tarde solo ahora en un
rato me llevo hasta compostela me voy al
andén de la estación de trenes de funes
y con otras personas maravillosas de acá
de la ciudad vamos a una charla abierta
gratuita como toda la actividad que
hacemos para tratar de contagiar a que
la gente arme su compostera y empiece a
compostar
pero les cuento es muy complicado está
muy muy muy difícil poder contagiar a
que los demás practiquen compostaje si
bien es algo totalmente sencillo les
cuento algo hace un par de días en una
de las páginas en facebook otra pregunta
que le quiero hacer todos usan facebook
voy a usar tanto no quien no usa
facebook acá por ejemplo quien no bueno
es todo un aprendizaje para mí tenemos
que empezar a interpretar nosotros
como vamos a seguir comunicando este
tipo de cosas el futuro es hoy
les contaba que hoy mejor dicho anteayer
en una de las páginas que más vistas con
funes un par de fotos te hará un par de
fotos terribles de basura que rebalsaba
gente quejándose 80.000 me gusta quejas
por doquier y yo abajo pregunté digo
alguno de ustedes hace compostaje
ninguno contestó quizás no lo vieron
entiendo de que hay una falla de la
comunicación entiendo por supuesto que
me hago cargo
igual vuelvo a decir somos simples
ciudadanos que estamos buscando
contagiar a otros para poder hacer una
masa crítica y generar ese cambio
contundente que es tan necesario
bueno ya le conté tenemos tres clubes a
funes roldán y fisherton aspiramos a que
haya otros clubes que haya clubes en
vecinales que haya clubes en escuelas
calles clubes a lo mejor de tres o
cuatro personas
no se requiere nada para crearlo
simplemente bueno en entender de qué
es muy importante no solamente por la
cantidad de dinero es por una cuestión
de calidad ambiental
a carbón pero toda gente joven pero en
esta ciudad en la que estamos viviendo
conocida como el jardín de la provincia
no se ven los paisajes que vemos hoy con
el tema de residuos y créanme porque
hace 10 años que estoy trabajando en el
tema que no hay decisión aún hoy para
poder revertir esta situación y siempre
digo lo mismo porque me ha pasado de
hablar con dirigentes políticos y que me
han dicho inclusive 'mario conseguido de
2000 firmas y esto va a pasar
pero bueno solamente tenemos tres clubes
no somos muchas las personas y también
me está pasando algo y se los cuento
entiendo de que hay una cuestión
generacional
yo tengo 46 años de todos mis amigos
siguen viendo estos temas
la gran mayoría como como un tema
chistoso como como hippie o como
ecológico y esto no es ecología yo estoy
hablando de sustentabilidad que es lo
medioambiental lo social y lo económico
de eso va a depender el futuro nuestro y
sobre todo el de ustedes en una ciudad
que tiene un impacto enorme porque acá
somos 30.000 40.000 personas pero
recibimos 90 mil los fines de semana y
el impacto no solamente se da en lo que
es la cultura vial y residuos que es
donde me pare en los últimos años se dan
montones de otras cosas que ustedes ya
las están viendo pero bueno la propuesta
nuestra hoy
está bien
primero que empiecen a comportar ustedes
que empiecen a probar que se está
apagada de radio metro cuadrado en casa
decirle mamá para la hierba la cáscara
de papas las frutas ahora van a ir acá
la bolsa que vamos a sacar afuera va a
pesar la mitad al no tener los orgánicos
dentro el perro que está fuera no lo va
a oler y no la va a romper y no va a
estar ocasionando estoy hablando de una
relación orgánica de las cosas
cotidianas que pasan acá el perro no va
a romper la bolsa no va a ver tantos
perros sueltos no va a ver tantos
accidentes ahí hablamos de tres impactos
todo por empezar a comportar después qué
va a pasar estamos hablando del 50 por
ciento de la basura vamos al otro 30 qué
es lo que podemos hacer en cada escuela
en cada club
no tenemos metros cuadrados ociosos para
poder recibir papel cartón plástico
abrigo en cuanto están pagando las
empresas está cerca para poder
transar esos papeles de cartón por
dinero por un cheque que a fin de año
les diga bueno nos vamos a la patagonia
nos vamos hacia a ver qué está pasando o
a dinamarca o suecia
sin nada hagan maratones se van a
divertir la van a pasar súper bien van a
conocer gente maravillosa como me tocó a
mí conocer gente que le dio la verdad
monjes tibetanos y guardaparques de
ushuaia una persona que traigo todos los
años este año espero traerla no
solamente van a empezar a medir las
cosas en la cantidad de basura que
disminuyen y los recursos que consiguen
van a empezar a medir un índice de
felicidad y de satisfacción inédito
iban a estar resolviendo un tema que
nosotros no pudimos resolver la última
pregunta
se van a ser hincha de este club quien
levanta la mano
[Música]